Star Trek creators have proven they know how
to turn on the funny since the beginning.
Whether it's entire episodes, hilarious scenes,
or little more than a couple of lines of dialogue,
here's what we count as the funniest
moments in the history of Star Trek.
One of the most fun conflicts
to witness on Star Trek:
Deep Space Nine is the back and forth between
Constable Odo and the scheming Ferengi Quark.
Perhaps their funniest exchange happens
in Season 4's "The Way of the Warrior,"
just before the epic battle between the
eponymous station and a fleet of Klingon ships.
Finding Quark outside his bar, Odo tells him
it's time to head to the emergency shelter,
but Quark assures Odo he intends to defend his
property. Quark isn't known for being able to
defend himself against so much as a tribble, much
less battle-hardened Klingon warriors, so Odo is
understandably skeptical. The bartender produces
a box that he thinks holds a disrupter pistol.
When he opens the box, boldly claiming he'll "be
ready for" the Klingons, rather than a weapon,
there's a note inside. Without skipping a beat or
asking permission, Odo grabs the note and reads
it — it's from Quark's brother Rom, informing him
he gutted his disruptor to fix their replicator.
It's here that Odo hits Quark with a real zinger:
"I will kill him!"
"With what?"
Deanna Troi's intrusive and flirtatious mother
Lwaxana, played by the late Majel Barrett,
provides a tremendous amount of
comic relief whenever she shows up.
In her third appearance on
Star Trek: The Next Generation,
her predicament forces Captain Picard to deliver
a speech so ridiculously over-the-top that even
if you've never watched TNG, you've
likely seen the memes inspired by it.
After Will Riker, Deanna, and Lwaxana
are kidnapped by the Ferengi DaiMon Tog,
Lwaxana succeeds in getting Riker and
her daughter sent back to the Enterprise
by promising to be Tog's lover. When the
Enterprise contacts Tog, Lwaxana pretends
she doesn't want to be rescued, telling
Picard that "it's over" between them.
Deanna figures out what her mother is doing
and tells Picard he will have to fight for her.
In a display so melodramatic it would
even make William Shatner groan,
Picard professes his love for Lwaxana,
threatens Tog with annihilation, and
recites famous lines from Shakespearean sonnets
with as much grandiose flair as he can muster.
"My love, is a fever, longing still for
that, which longer nurseth the disease."
Worf watches in disgust, looking
like he's about to rage-puke.
It's Picard like you've never seen him —
and probably wouldn't want to see him again.
In Star Trek: The Original Series, the season 2
episode "The Trouble with Tribbles" starts off
on a serious note. The Enterprise is already
on its way to Deep Space Station K-7, but they
put the pedal to the metal when they receive an
alert that their destination is under attack.
This alert proves to be a false
alarm, though dangers do await at K-7:
a domineering Federation bureaucrat, a Klingon
spy, and a space trader named Cyrano Jones who
sells members of the Enterprise crew some of the
most troublesome pets in the galaxy — tribbles.
"The Trouble with Tribbles" is a classic, and
one of the first examples of a whimsically goofy
original series episode that makes a point
of not taking itself too seriously. From the
countless puffballs that multiply faster than
a gremlin in a tropical storm to the ridiculous
barroom brawl between the Klingons and Enterprise
crew, to the peddler Cyrano Jones willing to risk
life and limb in order to score a free drink,
"The Trouble with Tribbles" is a great time.
To celebrate his upcoming marriage to
Jadzia in the DS9 episode titled "You
Are Cordially Invited," Worf invites Chief
O'Brien and Doctor Bashir, among others,
to the ritual of Kal'Hyah. Thinking they can
expect the Klingon version of a bachelor party,
they happily accept. But rather
than drinking or exotic dancers,
the path to Kal'Hyah involves fasting for
four days and nights, being drained of blood,
hanging from a pole over intense heat,
and other creative forms of torture.
When Worf abruptly cancels the wedding, Bashir and
O'Brien are thrilled to cut their torment short.
They head straight to Quark's for a feast,
but before they can sink their teeth in,
Sisko and Martok arrive to let them know
the wedding's back on. When Quark takes
their untouched food away, you can practically
hear them whining like disappointed puppies.
After several vows from both friends
that they're going to "kill Worf,"
the wedding finally arrives. Part of the
friends' duty — as per Klingon tradition — is
to attack Worf and Jadzia with blunted weapons
called Ma'Stakas. While everyone else applauds
the newlyweds' kiss, Bashir looks like Obi-Wan
Kenobi waiting for a force field to come down.
"Now?"
"Not yet."
When Martok finally gives the
word, Bashir and O'Brien rush
Worf and Jadzia with cries of rage and the
credits roll to sounds of the mock battle.
One of the best Star Trek films featuring
the original cast is 1986's Star Trek 4:
The Voyage Home. In order to
answer an alien probe's call,
which is blindly triggering power losses and
apocalyptic storms on Earth, Kirk and his
crew must go back in time to recover a humpback
whale — a species extinct by the 23rd century.
While original series sent the heroes back in time
on multiple occasions, none of those stories feel
as natural or believable as in Star Trek 4. Rather
than experiencing any particular physical threat,
the biggest challenge they face is
culture shock. They don't have money,
when they try to use a bus they're foiled by
the need for "exact change," and in particular
they're confused by what Spock calls, quote,
"colorful metaphors" — i.e. all the swearing.
The best scene involves Kirk and Spock trying
to earn the trust of the marine biologist Dr.
Gillian Taylor. Kirk is attempting, and failing,
to seem like the "normal" one compared to Spock.
When Kirk suggests the three of them
get dinner, one of the most natural,
adorably funny moments in the franchise unfolds:
"You guys like Italian?"
"No."
"Yes."
"No. "
"No."
"Yes. I love Italian."
Due to the meddling of the mischievous
entity Q — one of Star Trek's greatest
villains — Captain Picard, his
senior staff, and Picard's old flame
Vash find themselves transported to
Sherwood Forest in Season 4's "Qpid."
There's little about "Qpid" that won't make you
laugh. Picard and his senior officers are made
up as Robin Hood's merry men, including Data, who
bears the famous bald dome of Friar Tuck. Worf is,
predictably, the most incensed by the
situation, famously complaining to Picard,
"Sir, I protest. I am not a merry man!"
The most laugh-out-loud moment comes as Geordi
rests and plucks at his mandolin. Without comment
or permission, Worf calmly walks over, grabs the
instrument, and smashes it against a nearby tree.
The Prime Directive prohibits members of Starfleet
from interfering with the natural progression
of any society outside the United Federation
of Planets. Serving as a comically dangerous
example of why this code exists is the original
series Season 2 episode, "A Piece of the Action."
One hundred years before the events of the
episode, Sigma Iotia two is visited by the Earth
ship Horizon. To help teach the planet's natives,
the Horizon crew leaves behind a number of books,
including a non-fiction book titled "Chicago
Mobs of the Twenties." After the Horizon leaves,
the Iotians come to see this book as a holy text
and base their entire culture on it. When Kirk,
Spock, and McCoy beam down to the planet,
they find a world where just about
every grown male dresses and speaks
like tough guys in mobster movies.
People openly carry Tommy Guns up and down the
street as if there's nothing strange about it.
"A Piece of the Action" gets even funnier
once Kirk and Spock are outfitted in their
own mobster get-ups and Kirk attempts
a Chicago gangster impersonation.
Shatner wouldn't fool anyone on Earth, and
it's tough to tell whether that's intentional,
which just makes the whole thing even funnier.
Early in Season 5 of DS9, the series
made television history with "Trials
and Tribble-ations," where, the cast of
the show is sent back in time to the 1967
original series episode
"The Trouble with Tribbles."
This episode uses every opportunity to poke fun
at the franchise. O'Brien, the tireless engineer,
is so lost on the Enterprise that when he tries to
perform routine maintenance, he takes out all the
nearby lights. Bashir gets hit on by a woman he's
convinced is his great-grandmother, and afterward
he considers the possibility that if he doesn't
get involved with her, he might never be born.
Hands down, the best moment comes when a
waitress points out a table full of Klingons.
Everyone but Worf is confused, because,
of course, Klingons look a lot different
in the original series. It's the
first time in the franchise anyone
acknowledges what appears to be a glaring
inconsistency, and it comes off perfectly.
"They are Klingons. And it is a long story."
Imagine you're suddenly transported to the
23rd century and you need to use a computer
more advanced than anything you'd ever
seen. Now consider the opposite scenario,
and that's what happens in Star Trek 4.
On their quest to bring 20th-century humpback
whales back to the 23rd century, Scotty, McCoy,
and Sulu are tasked with figuring out a way to
construct a makeshift aquarium aboard the Bounty.
While Sulu secures an aircraft, Scotty and McCoy
find a plexiglass manufacturer and pretend to be
famous scientists with an appointment to
tour the factory. At the end of the tour,
Scotty plans to offer the head of the
plant, Dr. Nichols, the futuristic
formula for transparent aluminum, but he needs
to use Nichols' computer to prove it can work.
Unfortunately, Scotty has a little trouble...
"Computer?"
"Computer!"
Thinking he's figured it out,
McCoy hands Scotty the mouse.
Smiling widely, Scotty holds the mouse to
his face like a walkie talkie and says,
"Hello, computer."
"Just use the keyboard."
1989's Star Trek 5: The Final Frontier
is considered one of the worst films in the
series, though it is not without its merits.
While it's one of the funnier entries in
the franchise, some of its detractors would
argue that the movie's over-reliance
on humor weighs it down. But one easy,
uncharacteristically slapstick moment in Star
Trek 5 remains as an incredibly uproarious gag.
After the forces loyal to Spock's fanatical
brother Sybok seize control of the Enterprise,
Kirk, Spock, and Dr. McCoy
are imprisoned in the brig.
Scotty soon frees them with explosives,
and the liberated trio makes a plan to
sneak their way to the emergency transmitter.
When the subject of search parties comes up,
Scotty gives them directions he's confident
will steer them clear of Sybok's people.
Before they rush off, Kirk emphatically
thanks Scotty and calls him "amazing."
Turning and walking in the
other direction, Scotty mutters,
"There's nothing amazing about it. I
know this ship like the back of my hand."
If that were true though, he should have
easily been able to avoid that bulkhead.
It's perfectly timed and classic.
If you understand the context,
the single-word response Worf delivers to
Quark in the season 4 DS9 episode "Accession"
should make you laugh hard enough to knock you
out of any recliner, couch, or captain's chair.
Dr. Bashir and O'Brien are
sharing a drink in Quark's bar,
discussing the news that O'Brien's wife
Keiko is pregnant with another baby.
It's just then that, behind Bashir and
O'Brien, Quark runs into Worf and says,
"Did you hear? Keiko's
going to have another baby."
To understand what happens next,
you need to know that five years
earlier in the Season 5 TNG episode
"Disaster," much of the Enterprise
is rendered inoperable and most of the crew
is stranded in different parts of the ship.
This, of course, is when Keiko O'Brien —
pregnant with her first baby — goes into
labor while stuck in Ten Forward. As the most
qualified crew member — but still with precious
little medical knowledge — Worf is the one
who's forced to assist with Keiko's pregnancy.
So this is why, five years later in
"Accession," when Quark delivers the news,
Worf's immediate reaction is
to respond with a panicked,
"Now?!?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Trek
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.